اخبار عمليه طوفان الاقصى بايجاز من
الجليل الاعلى اهلا بكم قصف اسرائيلي
متواصل على قطاع غزه يدمر احياء باكملها
وعدد الشهداء يرتفع الى اكثر من
2300 بينهم ما لا يقل عن
730 طفلا وزاره الصحه في القطاع تقول ان
شهيدا يسقط كل خمس دقائق وكتائب القسام
تعلن قصف تلبيب عسقلان ونيم ردا على مجازر
الاحتلال بحق
المدنيين وعلى الحدود اللبنانيه
الاسرائيليه اشتباكات بالاسلحه المتوسطه
بين الجيش الاسرائيلي وحزب الله حزب الله
يعلن استهدافه لدبابه اسرائيليه في موقع
الراهب الحدودي وتحقيق اصابات مؤكده في
صفوف قوه اسرائيليه في بلده شتوه في الجلي
والاسعاف الاسرائيلي يؤكد مقتل شخص واصابه
اربعه تزامنا مع اعلان اسرائيل البلدات
قرب الحدود مع لبنان منطقه عسكريه
مغلقه وعلى صعيد ردود الفعل الدوليه ولي
العهد السعودي يؤكد خلال لقائه بوزير
الخارجيه الامريكي ان بلاده ترفض استهداف
المدنيين وتعطيل البنى التحتيه في غزه
مؤكدا ضروره احتراب القانون الدولي
الانساني بينما صرح وزير الخارجيه
الايراني للجزيره انه لا يمكن لبلاده ان
تبقى متفرجه ازاء هذا الوضع وان اتساع
الحرب امر غير
مستبعد الذكاء الاصطناعي يكشف كذبه
اسرائيليه خبراء وفنيون يكشفون ان الصوره
التي وزعها رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي على
انها جثه متفحمه لطفل اسرائيلي احرقته
حماس خلال عمليه طوفان الاقصى هي صوره
مفبركه باستخدام الذكاء الاصطناع
ووسائل اعلام غربيه وسياسيون يتراجعون
ويعتذرون عن حملات تبنت المزاعم
الاسرائيليه دون
دليل الى
اللقاء